what is going on that a woman can
actually say I feel terrible that that
woman got a really expensive car right
that's a man thing right or I feel
terrible that that woman bought this
beautiful house because I don't I don't
have that and to feel as bad or worse
than men and overall for more we had 22
items women fell worse
over the last few months one of the most
interesting topics that I've learned
about has been intra-sexual competition
and particularly
female intersexual competition because I
think it's overlooked a lot when we're
talking about status seeking behavior
when we're talking about competitiveness
immediately everybody goes to men as the
uh how would you say the prime example
that's the flagship example of what
we're talking about a lot of your work
has looked at the unique and quite
vicious ways that females enact their
intra sexual competition their status
seeking Behavior so what is unique about
the female competition for status when
you compare it with males
okay well I guess I have a recent paper
where I argue that females more than
males engage in safe
um subtle and solitary forms of
competition so this is a comparison and
by safe I've done a lot of work and many
others have
um suggesting that across animal species
females need to stay alive more so males
can take risks so you could have one
male uh live fast uh Die Young right one
male who inseminates lots of females and
he dies very early in life but he's
still going to leave a lot of Offspring
so whether that's humans or others
doesn't matter and he doesn't have to
worry that much about survival but
females if we're talking about mammals
are the ones who have to take care of
The Offspring and this certainly goes
for humans and not only do mothers but
grandmothers and humans so we're really
taking care of Offspring for many many
decades
um have to take care of Offspring so
it's no good to engage in dangerous
tactics that would be stupid in terms of
being able to take care of your
Offspring and your grandchildren too so
number one I would say females are safe
and part of being safe is if you have a
competitive interaction if you have a
conflict
you better be subtle about it because if
you go up as a male might and you know
punch somebody in the face or um
verbally harangue them or engage in any
kind of very non-subtle direct Behavior
then that's more likely to invite
retaliation so uh retaliation obviously
can lead to a lot of injury and even
death and that males across many species
are willing to do that because again as
I said before they can still leave many
offspring but females can't because
after a long period of gestating and
lactating you have to invest in
protecting your Offspring and usually
without the help of the male and with
humans it varies whether there's a male
to help or not whether the father's
around another male not clear so it's
very important again that one is subtle
in conflicts in competition and and so
what do we do we develop all kinds of
different types of tactics for competing
and they have to do with non-verbal
gestures
um voice internet Nation change that's
derogatory talking about somebody who
you want to get rid of this is
particularly obviously in humans if
you're talking
um where you socially exclude someone so
other females are around and you say
oftentimes in a very sweet way did you
know that this
woman did this terrible thing and um
you're trying to kind of I I think it's
said very well by a number of women
where they say it in a sympathetic
fashion but of course it's letting out
terrible information about someone at
the same at the same time so you know
it's so awful that this happened to
whoever and then everybody there knows
and they wouldn't have known otherwise
and that reduces her you know uh
reputation with everyone else so these
kinds of subtle tactics obviously
they're much safer but you know they're
something that I believe are honed over
many years but I see it even in
three-year-old girls where it's like did
you see she she's so bossy and that's a
very common complaint where uh boys
don't like bossy boys either but they'll
they'll punch them and run over their
heads I mean I've actually seen that and
that's
that you have to deal with that so you
know you can argue about oh I don't even
say it's a comparison like which is
worse and people can go back and forth
but it's just different and I do think
it is very different I I don't think
it's the same at all and so I get
surprised when people think there are no
sex differences and I'm like have you
ever been to a preschool and this is
pretty early in life I've done my work
primarily with children though more
recently with adults but you know
um preschool is so obvious you have the
girls on one side and the boys on the
other and so you're socializing
something that they naturally do but
it's socialized then for the next rest
of your life where because of sex
segregation girls are more comfortable
with the girls and boys are more
comfortable with the boys so you get a
lot of practice doing this and you learn
what it's like to be the butt of that
and you learn to avoid it if at all
possible so um this is socialization I
think a lot of people talk about
socialization is coming from adults or
parents or the media or social media or
whatever and sure that's there but to me
the power of social media as opposed to
television or adults or even parents is
that it peers and there's nothing
stronger than peers as socializers I I
just don't think people have understood
that so you know by the time you're
three you put a child into a daycare or
preschool or whatever in a
hunter-gatherer Society just a group
whoever's there and the peers have a lot
to say about whether you have someone to
talk to and somebody near you or whether
you're all by yourself which nobody
wants so it's very very powerful
and the third thing I talk about is
solitary competition this is just one
from one of my papers and I do think a
big part a big attraction of competition
for males is making it public so you
want to be able to show off that you
beat this guy and right now watching
tennis matches because I did a study on
um what happens at the end of a tennis
match but you know that's what males
want they want public conspicuous
um contests and the more people watching
the better off and that's of course
risky if you happen to be the loser but
it's it gives the thrill gets the
testosterone going the challenge
um females they're new relatively to
sports certainly uh research over the
last many centuries and across the world
has shown males are much more likely to
play sports It's Not Just Sports it's
verbal contests it's any kind of
competitive Behavior males want it
public they want it conspicuous and then
they want it to be clear who's a winner
who's the loser that's the way it goes
in contrast females I find are much much
more solitary in their competition but
it doesn't mean they're not competing it
means that for example
um I once went to a store where somebody
asked me if I were I was I was older
than this but they asked me if I was
going to the local prom and I said no
I'm not going to local problem why and
the the store owner said oh we have to
write down everybody's dress
to make sure that no woman gets or girl
gets the same dress because that would
be really bad but what the girls do is
they try to find who has the best dress
and that's very important so if you can
go farther and if you can spend more
money and get a prettier dress then
that's competing in a solitary fashion
what I call what uh kind of evolutionary
biologists call scramble competition so
I'm not going into contests I'm not
going to yank your dress away from you
right I'm not going to go over to your
house and steal it I'm not going to do
something that's very direct and
dangerous rather I'm gonna go off and
I'm gonna see oh here are the dresses at
the store where everybody else is going
but I can go to a better store or I can
find clothing some other place or just
the same with um finding a mate or
finding any food if you can not engage
in a contest it's much better it's much
safer so females will be more likely to
do that that's scramble competition that
yeah I mean it's my example it's called
scramble competition but it's my example
of solitary competition which is still
competition it's much harder to notice
because it's not purposefully
conspicuous it's purposefully not
conspicuous and then you show up for the
prom and you look better than everyone
yes is this the same Dynamic that is
causing girls to outperform in school
that in Academia you are an individual
you are competing with the group but
it's not directly it's it's you versus
this sort of just miscellaneous blob of
the grade distribution
yeah I mean my sense with Academia is
number one girls like it more and they
always have you know and they always
outperformed it's just they weren't
allowed in a lot of educational
institutions so that's why that's my
belief as well yeah yes okay but I think
it's it's absolutely true that number
one they like it more but
there's this sense that oh my gosh it's
luck that I did so well in the exam and
really I don't want to talk about it as
opposed to haha I got a better Mark than
you which is the male way and I've heard
that so many times you know where a a
boy or you know a young man will say boy
I just killed you on this exam and then
it makes it public and it makes it a
contest versus the girls and the young
women they really want to do well
particularly now where it you know it
leads to to University and um a higher
paying job
um it's very important but it needs to
be done subtly why why does it need to
be done subtly what's the dynamic that's
driving this desire to be under the
surface okay so underlying it all I
would say is this sense that we are all
equals so if my friend does much better
than me on an exam and I find out about
it I feel bad it's like who who is she
and what am I and maybe I don't want to
be friends with her anymore and I've
done quite a bit of research on that how
do you feel if your friend does better
than you and this is all same sex and
um women or girls both feel worse about
it and there's a lot of evidence now
that's coming out in the business
literature and certainly in academic
literature and even in in
um I find it by middle childhood when I
first done it girls don't like somebody
who is showing off who's bragging who's
doing exactly what boys and men like to
do and even if you look at a lot of
qualitative studies in young young
children anybody who's trying to be
better than anyone else is really
disliked within the female Community
whatever age it is so this showing off
is really painful and of course we go
then right to social media which is
totally new and it's horrible and we
know that girls are much more likely and
women to be addicted to social media
than boys and men boys and men are much
more likely to have gaming addictions so
you can argue about which is worse but
what we're talking about now is social
behavior and it's really really painful
to see someone you know doing much
better than you unbelievably painful
and I believe that's because on top of
um my safe solitary subtle
tactics right
um there is this ethos within human
females of everybody needing to be the
same everybody needing to be equal and
it's very very important now boys and
men their whole
um stick as far as I can tell is no I'm
better than you and it may be in
three-year-olds I'm better at jumping in
the air or I'm better at running or I'm
better at making a paper airplane or I'm
better at whatever it can be anything it
can be the silliest thing but what's
nice about the way they do it is a lot
of times everybody gets to be better at
something right everybody who's a member
of the group and I I see this and I sort
of admire it in some way because it's
yeah okay I'm not that good at making
paper airplanes but hey I can jump
higher than you and you know and so
everybody has their thing and that that
sort of kind of nice because you can get
better and better at your thing and you
can brag about your thing knowing full
well you're not maybe so good at
something else versus is the girls
it's really looked a sconce upon you
know girls look very upset when somebody
else is doing better it's not nice and
so what you have to do then is
hide your achievement make it solitary
and there's books on this which I find
fascinating qualitative books where a
girl or woman will say I don't know how
I got to be the way I am it's nothing
about me it's just luck I happen to you
know do well at my dance and I'm a top
dancer or I look this beautiful or I you
know did got 100 on this exam and I
don't know how it is and you know it's
just mostly it's luck and and that's the
way it is and I don't really want to
talk about it anymore and that's how it
ends up you know because it's not
something that other girls and women who
aren't at the top
want to hear about if you're equal if
you have others who are at your level
then it's okay but otherwise
um it's very very unpleasant and so I
think there's less leeway there for
girls to achieve in public with friends
and and social media I think is just
crushing now but the pressure of
restricting public achievement two girls
is coming from girls mostly this doesn't
appear to be men that are
misogynistically keeping women down it's
their concern about what other women are
going to say about them
I would say number one that's what it is
now across societies men have definitely
put down women there's no question I
mean men put down everyone so I mean men
will try to put down one another and
beneath the men are the women
um so yeah they're that's what men do
and part of it is misogyny and part of
it is anything they can find to put down
everyone whether it's racial groups or
whatever it's like I you know it's my
friends me too right I've heard male
friends at all ages just saying you know
what a loser their friend is their
tennis player is you know what and you
know I and it is interesting because I I
am just watching tennis matches now and
I you know women oftentimes will say oh
I'm sorry when they hit a really good
shot I mean that sort of doesn't make a
lot of sense but this is just informal
tennis this isn't top tennis players but
it is true it's this idea of geez here I
am trying to win the game and beat you
but I'm sorry that I hit such a good
shot so that's a contradiction and it's
because which I understand well I mean I
do it myself
um you know it's like how do you put
together these things that don't really
match I'm trying to do very well but you
know I don't want to you not to like me
so I'm stuck and is the driver that's
underneath this I'm trying to work out
why women want everybody to seem this
egalitarian sort of flat landscape I'm
trying to work out what the Adaptive
pressure is that's caused this to be the
case like why why would it not be the
case that men do that and why would it
be the case that women do that
okay so um this takes us into uh kind of
my work looking at primatology so I'll
give you a little bit of background on
that
um you can stop me because it may not be
that interesting but basically if you
look across a lot of primate species
males always are trying to be better
than one another because they get more
mating success so whoever's on top gets
to meet with the most females and they
leave their genes and those genes are
trying to get to the top so that's what
gets left across primates there there's
almost no exceptions to that I mean
there's very many different kinds of
social organizations and and so forth
but that's how it goes
for females it's quite different because
there's two societies that
um
cause very different effects in females
in one you live with your kin for your
whole life that's fabulous you have
coalitions you put down others who are
not your kin you put down lower ranked
members of your kinship group and you
have your allies for life you're born
into your kin group you've got your
mother you've got your aunts you've got
your grandmother you've got your sisters
and you're going to stay together for
Life the males will eventually disperse
at adolescence and you have this great
situation where you don't have to figure
out who your family is who your friends
are because your friends are your family
there you are okay but there's another
group much smaller where females
disperse at adolescence and the male
stay or both males and females disperse
but the females in either of those
latter cases are not staying with their
family not staying with their female kin
for their whole lives they are Inhumans
usually marrying into a husband's family
in most places or the majority of places
in the world at least
some parts of their life women are
spending their time with their husband's
family and there's a lot of going back
and forth and humans but in non-humans
it's very very common in these groups
that a female will join a male
um what we call phylopatric Society but
basically male kin who have who are
staying there their whole lives now
who are the other females that are there
those females are not related to you
they're not individual you individuals
you grew up with they're not your female
kin they're nobody they're totally
unfamiliar and they also need the food
and they need the mating partners and
they need their offspring to be taken
care of so what happens in those
societies and what's really interesting
is the research has shown very clearly
that the females stay away from each
other they're much more individualistic
maybe after many many years they might
form a bond and stay close to one
another but they demand equality there
is not a lot of status
um
altercations or fighting status accrues
over time you've been there a long time
you're a resident okay so you're ahead
of the ones who immigrate more recently
that's it but generally everybody stays
away from each other if you're female
there's no advantage to fighting one
another you try to get the food on your
own in a solitary safe and subtle Manner
and it really applies to non-humans as
well so what I have argued in my most
recent paper is that humans have some
kind of bias that is similar so we are
not surrounded by kin usually they're
Exceptions there are societies that are
um matrilineal and and the female can
are around but they're rare so who's
your gonna be your partner well if
you're really lucky you might have a
female partner you grew up with so you
know you've known her your entire life
and that's pretty Irreplaceable and you
can probably count on her and then maybe
you're in a much better shape and you
can take on other females but otherwise
it's females who are unfamiliar you form
friendships but you're always concerned
who's going to be your friend who's not
they're not stable life changes and so
you have to say okay we're gonna all
come to this ostensible agreement that
we're equal and then I'll try to get the
most stuff I can for myself when
nobody's looking and that's basically
this is coming out of non-human you know
Primate Research and even non-prime
research if you don't live with kin for
females it's very hard to have
long-term coalitions there was a story
that Rob Henderson told me from a book
where a French girl I want to say in the
1800s was kidnapped by an Amazonian
tribe
so have you seen that you know the story
I'm about to do no okay so there's this
French girl who gets kidnapped I I don't
know why what she's doing in the Amazon
anyway she is and she gets brought into
this tribe and maybe they were going to
kill her but they end up not killing her
and she's now a part of the tribe and
upon one of the first days that she
arrives one of the women around about
her age one of the other girls that's in
the tribe gives her a little parcel and
she says um if you want you can eat this
and if you don't want to eat it then you
can give it to somebody else it's a
little parcel wrapped with leaves anyway
this girl decides to
open it up and smells it smells awful so
she puts it back down puts it to one
side leaves it doesn't think about it
again she goes away
after she's gone away a little bit later
one of the young boys in this tribe gets
unbelievably sick gets ridiculously sick
and they ask him who did you get this
parcel from and he had seen the new girl
just put it down and push it to one side
what had happened was the local tribe's
girl had created some sort of poison
food thing that she had hoped the new
girl was going to eat and what she'd
said is the contingency remember what
she said if you don't want it you can
give it to somebody else so she then
left it on the side this boy had gone
over and eaten it and they're all up in
arms she has to run away from this tribe
Through the Jungle barefooted being
chased down with Spears and arrows being
thrown after her because this one other
girl that already existed had done a
solitary subtle and uh safe way to be
able to get this particular girl to the
new competitor to get her away
amazing yeah amazing I mean I think you
know we love these stories The co-wives
Who poison one another's children and
you know uh get very jealous of their
husband and you know so forth we love
these stories now I always want to say
men are the ones that are killing each
other 90 of homicides around the world
are men and they're male male homicides
right so females are not nearly as bad
for for the planet for for one another
and so forth but I think men also get
along in a way that that women don't
it's just easier they don't take things
as seriously they don't have to worry as
much as women do and so who are the
people that women can depend on most
it's not the kind of situation you just
described absolutely not the other women
well the interesting thing that I've
taken from learning about your work is
this
um push toward to World egalitarianism
from women a lot of the time
from the outside ostensibly looks like
this sort of beautiful
hedonic kind of bliss Paradise that
we're moving toward
Until you realize that it can be just as
self-serving as saying I want it to be a
ruthless meritocracy or even something
an oligopoly or a monopoly right I can
have it it's all for me just me and my
friends and screw everybody else you
realize well the egalitarian side of
things if you're a non-super high status
woman what you're actually doing there
is flattening the field by bringing
everybody else down unless you're at the
very top of the tree egalitarianism is
more again for you than it is a loss
exactly and I just did a study on that
it's just sent out for publication now
where I find that
um women and this was done in South
Africa online South Africa the UK and
and here in the US
um women are more likely to try to force
a higher same-sex individual to share
with them equally than men are men would
rather try a contest even in some ways
rather stupidly against a higher ranked
individual they'd rather try even if
they're going to lose and that's
fascinating to me it's very clear result
and it's exactly what you said because
egalitarianism sounds nice except when
you realize I won't accept you being
better than me and it's not clear that
women are helping out
um really honestly those who are less
good than they are either there's a
really strong bias for I'm just going to
spend time with those who are like me
exactly so it does have I think uh
connotation of being very positive but I
don't see it like that
um how do we relate the
female status seeking competitive drives
how does that relate to mate seeking and
sort of female mate Choice sexual
selection make preferences so on and so
forth
yeah I mean it's you know what what's
confusing about this is there if you
look across species obviously there's so
many different mating regimes right so
if if you look in humans obviously
there's there is polygyny around the
world but it's a small percentage most
of it is monogamy there's a huge benefit
for a woman to have a husband
um just in terms of providing support
now In fairness husbands aren't that
important when you're female kid around
and the female kin probably are in most
hunter-gatherer societies they do a lot
more for you than the husband the
husband is more of a community man and
kind of gives you a connection to the
community I'm not sure how much men are
really helpful to women I I really am
not I need to I need to I need to jump
in there I had a conversation with uh
Roy Baumeister and Robin Dunbar this
year and Robin Dunbar taught me about
The Bodyguard hypothesis which I
basically asked it seems like women are
pretty capable of looking after
themselves in the modern world we have
women outperforming men both in
education and employment on average
they're more conscientious in terms of
Personality ancestrally they had this
aloe parenting thing going on where they
were able to disperse the child rearing
amongst both friends and family I was
like
I'm not I'm not being stupid here but
what's what is the point of men like
give me tell me why we're here and he
said well you know Warfare and a big
game were really sort of the two main
reasons of that occurring and obviously
we've got this whole crisis of
masculinity in the feminization of men
concern going on at the moment but when
you realize that Warfare has been
outsourced to the state in both policing
of local laws in the military for
international laws and then in terms of
big game hunting like there's a
supermarket down the street so the two
main things that men did have kind of
been supplanted by the state and the
thing that women do the child rearing
has not certainly not as much
um so yeah I'm I am uh on board with the
ongoing question what is the use of men
in like the nicest way possible
I I think it's an excellent point and
really important and a big big concern
now for everyone
um I think what I feel sad about is I
feel men and boys right from early on
get along really really well in groups
and there's a lot of ability to
um have fights to reconcile to um to
compete to try to do as well as each
individual can do and to admire that and
so there's a lot of things I try to
emphasize that that boys and men do
right and and that can be used what I
think is a shame is that Society hasn't
come up with more Community Based
Ventures for men and there are so many I
mean our environment is falling apart
these require huge Solutions
firefighting who's out there fighting
the fires obviously we know it's mostly
men if there's any huge accidents who's
out there it's it's men so you know
Roy's book I love is there anything good
about men it's just a terrific book and
it you know I can just recite from that
there are tons of things that men do
that women are afraid to do but I would
go farther and say look our environment
needs trees planted we need all kinds of
solar panels we need nuclear power
whatever it is that you think is the
best solution to what the climate crisis
and to you know Recycling and all the
things that will allow us to continue as
a species we need men to do that because
we need those who are not next to the
children all the time who work really
well in groups who can coordinate so if
we could only see
um a war on environmental destruction
that needs to be fought by man and I
really really think all of this is very
true so we're just not defining the
problems properly I think a challenge
that you have when it comes to climate
specifically is that it's so
ungalvanizing is a problem you know
there is no war boring tribe coming over
the hill with face paint on and a pelt
around his waist and his todger hanging
out swinging in the flapping in the wind
like there isn't anything for you to do
you know
um it is this sort of
miscellaneous ethereal problem just
washing through okay so um women sexual
selection mating strategy how does that
relate to their competition and Status
seeking
okay so there still is a huge benefit to
having a man so if we talk about modern
society or I should say Western Society
um because every society is modern
that's that's around now
um there is a huge benefit because women
are very isolated from their kin and and
that to me is such an important point
that needs to be reiterated over and
over so rearing children in our modern
society is not or in our Western Society
is not easy there aren't others around
to help us out yeah you're really lucky
if your mother can come come for a
couple weeks and help you out in a bad
time but generally she doesn't live next
door so therefore having a man who one
can help with earning money and two can
help if the mother gets sick and three
can help in terms of keeping up Social
contacts there's a lot of evidence that
women benefit enormously from having a
husband that's really supportive of them
and when women want a husband who has
higher status than they do and I don't
care if you have the highest status when
you could possibly find she still wants
I mean the examples I can give just
floor me you know she still wants a man
who has much much higher status so you
know it's very clear that women around
the world these Studies have been done
by David Buss and others you know women
want higher status men that's very very
important to them so it may just be a
day-to-day you know support system and I
think it's very important because we
live in these nuclear families to have
someone there who's friendly who is an
insurance policy who can bring in the
money if women want to take time off and
despite all the you know glowing reports
of women doing so well in education and
achievement a lot of women don't want to
work they would like to be near their
children for at least part of the day
and not have to work 12-hour days and so
having a man who's another person who's
in your house who's willing to do that
and who you get along with well and
who's the father of your children is a
huge huge benefit now
I just am contradicting myself because I
said oh what's the point of men in our
society there's a huge point of men you
know there really is and of course then
you can go to the genes there are
enormous differences between men more so
than between women just in terms of
traits at least that's what the research
shows and so having a man that has
really good traits means your children
are more likely to survive which we
still care about and Thrive which women
care tremendously about in terms of you
know attaining whatever status they can
in the society they're from so there's a
huge advantage and it's very clear
across societies that when you have
single mothers they're having a much
harder time than married mothers and
it's just huge and so in our society it
makes a big difference one of the
interesting stats that I learned about
children who are raised in single parent
households which when you say single
parent what you mean a single mother
it's very rare that you're going to be
raised by a single father right it needs
to be some very unusual situation to
occur for that to be the case
the educational outcomes of girls coming
out of single mother households are no
different to the educational outcomes of
girls coming out from Twin parent
households now you do get some changes
to do with anti-social Behavior Uh
sexual
um Behavior as well like sociosexuality
and stuff like that
um
but
when we're talking about single parent
households are bad for outcomes in
education and employment you can double
whatever the rate is that you think and
then smear that exclusively onto men
um because it seems like girls are okay
at performing in education and
employment with just a mother whereas
boys with just a mother really really
underperformed this is in Richard Reeves
book of boys and men which came out this
year which it sounds like you're
familiar with so one of the other things
as well talking about boys and men
anti-social behavior is something that
is often kind of laid at the feet of
boys and men it's mostly a male
phenomenon but one of the things that
you've brought up today is how much
women exclude others so what do you
think is it is it fair to say that men
are more anti-social than women on
average or is it just a different lens
that you need to look at anti-sociality
through
well I mean um to me antisocial is a
really funny name because a lot of the
anti-social behavior is done in a social
context so it's it's you know unless
you're talking about you know death of
Despair where men are overdosing on
drugs which you know that's happening to
some extent but a lot of anti-social
behavior is males having a great time
with one another and causing wreaking
havoc on society so it's very social I I
know anti-social what is it there were
some aspo order in the UK and
anti-social Behavior order yeah yeah I I
find that so funny because I lived in
the UK for for two years and sometimes I
would go to the restaurant and there
would be these gangs of men
screaming and yelling and drunk and
terrifying the rest of us so it was
anti-social but they the reason it was
anti-social is because they were so
social they were such a strong coach
they were being as social as they wanted
it was anti-social to everybody else
exactly so I think it's a real shame
that we don't harness that and admire
that in men because it's so strong and
what I find amazing is how um much leave
it leeway there is for men to have a
fight with each other and then make up
and then reconcile and that these are
really strong abilities and I don't
understand
um why as a society we can't build
schools and build what Richard Reeves
talked about technical schools that are
really fascinating
um to males in particular and one thing
I can say is in some of my classes the
the women do
really well and oftentimes get higher
grades than the men and they're much
more likely to show up for a class and
be conscientious and all that but the
males will get into a project if I
cannot find them a project they like and
that's it they're completely involved
absorbed they want to learn everything
about it in a way that it's not just a
school project as it is for the the
young women and the men are fascinated
and they go down that rabbit hole and
they love it and they learn a huge
amount so you know when we talk about
specialty training I could see that in
you know grade one you know early on in
in in life and boys with their dinosaurs
or their cars and their trucks or
whatever they're totally interested in
things and I think unfortunately
schools are female right they're run by
women they're set up by women you have
to sit there which is something the boys
don't want to do so the only time I look
at kids is at the playground where it's
free time and they can do what they want
and then you see super social boys they
may be doing anti-social things from the
teacher's perspective but that I think
we're missing that the the all the
positive things that that boys have as
well what was that
um observation that you did where
looking at young boys and girls and
finding that um boys made enemies they
created enemies but girls kept things
alive as like two categorizations of how
they were playing
uh okay yeah I mean boys love enemies
obviously they spend a lot of time and
if only we could make environmental
destruction an enemy in some way I
always think about that it would be so
useful but yeah whether it's you know
sharks or or Killers or martians or
anything whatever it is um boys love
that and they can spend hours devising
ways to to kill that individual who is
their enemy and it brings boys together
enemies are a real draw and and you know
they have a great time and you know
girls are concerned about survival and
this is a theme that I have spent so
much time looking at recently and women
and our bodies I think are designed to
Keep Us Alive more than boys and men
bodies are so there's a lot of evidence
for that and in in preschool which is I
think what you're referring to you know
girls will say oh my gosh you know the
rabbit died and then they'll spend a lot
and a lot of time trying to bring the
rabbit back to life bring it to the
house possible getting the doctor you
know trying to feed it and and give it
sleep and medicine and whatever and
survival is so critical absolutely
critical
um two I think girls and women
that's so interesting I'm just thinking
about the sort of toys that I remember
playing with and I see my friends kids
playing with and I think it's Plants
Versus Aliens is a really popular uh
computer game that then got turned into
toys mostly for boys uh Nerf guns you
know they're weapons of war they're
mostly used by boys but I always kind of
got
surprised I was puzzled by the fact that
girls always wanted
um a doll and then sometimes there would
be kind of doctor or nurse paraphernalia
that came with it this is a pretend
syringe and this is a stethoscope and
this is a little hat that I can wear and
what is that well you're playing the
role of the life Giver the life keeper
uh whereas the boys are creating some
tribal game so
stop me when I stop bro silencing too
much is this because
on average it would have been adaptive
for males to be used to tribal Warfare
to be able to create an us and them
mentality to be able to bond together
very quickly with other members of an
in-group over the mutual destruction or
defense against an out group whereas for
women and females it would have been
much more adaptive for them to
understand what it means for something
to be alive what it means for something
to be close to dead how it means that
you're supposed to either bring it back
or stop it from being dead is that the
the dynamic and sort of the thrust
that's causing these two things to
happen yeah well I think there's two
reasons that men and boys very early on
Love weapons love
um uh getting together in a group and
defeating enemies love competing to be
the best and then attacking
um one is this Warfare this is pretty
unusual in in the human species I mean
there are other species but it's pretty
rare which requires a lot of cooperation
and keeping your eye on the enemy and
the other is across species males
who want to inseminate females have to
compete it's not an automatic thing in a
lot of uh species many males never get
to mate they never get to have any
Offspring and in humans there still are
huge differences between men some men
don't ever produce any Offspring and
some men produce Lots so there's this
constant pressure to be better than the
other males but it's sort of
um
balanced out by this Warfare well I
can't get in too much trouble with the
other males for too long because
otherwise should the enemy attack we
need each other so so I think that those
two
competition cooperation and going back
and forth I think are critical parts of
the male psyche and not the female
psyche I think the female psyche is
really been fashioned through Evolution
and through socialization it goes with
Evolution to keep children alive that
that's the most important thing because
our genes depend on a lot of work a
lifetime of work a tremendous amount of
you know investment whether it's from
just dating for nine months or you know
lactation requires a lot of energy and
food if we're talking about
hunter-gatherer Society
um and then years and years and years in
protection and of course if you want to
really have high status it requires
education and socialization and so many
things and the number one most important
thing that I think a girl or a woman
thinks about is is someone going to die
you know so you know my son left today
on a plane and all I can think of is you
know is the plane gonna crash I can't
help it you know I I'm terrified and I
think this is ridiculous you know I look
at the statistics and but I think this
is a part of what women are talking
about and I was in the hairdresser uh
two days ago and there was a woman there
and she was talking about the fact that
there's a a young woman who died in
tragic circumstances around here in New
Hampshire Mountain she went hiking all
by herself in in the you know it was
last month and she died on her 20th
birthday because she got stuck in a
horrible storm and so this woman was
going on and on and on about this you
know in the hairdresser
um and and I'm thinking oh she's got
some of the details wrong I wonder if I
should correct her because I too was
obsessed with how could this 20 year old
woman go hiking by herself in the middle
of a storm you know it was like
fascinating to me and of course all the
hairdressers were women so all of us
were and then the woman who's who
started with this story started talking
about her blood pressure her blood
pressure is 149 over 90 which is very
high everybody in the whole hairdresser
knows this and so we're all even though
we're all separate we're all like oh my
you're like what is she gonna do and of
course the theme running through the
entire conversation of this woman
speaking very loudly and she seemed like
ugly person was
is she gonna die right and if she's
gonna die who's going to take care of
you know but she's so here we have dead
women and we have women who have health
problems and I think that's the major
stream of a woman's life her own health
and her family's health that's very
interesting the male denial of medical
problems is like just such a that's the
real pandemic if we want to talk about
the genuine pandemic it's the fact that
guys don't want to admit that there's
something going on until the point at
which they need to go into the the
hospital not even to their friends
um one of the questions that I had in
the back of my mind when looking at the
subtlety and the increased desire that
women have for non-direct non-physical
conflict was that women's ability to use
lethal force is significantly lower than
men's right when it comes to uh Am I
Wrong a man when it comes to a man yeah
so a female ability to use a lethal
Force presumably is lower than a man's
we look at the statistics around the
attempts of suicide is significantly
higher amongst women but the number of
people that take their own life is
higher amongst men because the use of
lethal force from men is more effective
so what I saw in my mind was this kind
of a paradox I'm thinking why would it
be the case that females try to avoid
direct and physical conflict
when the potential risk should be lower
because presuming that it's up against
another woman her
um lethality should be lower but what it
seems like is yes maybe The lethality of
the person that you're going up against
is lower but the externality and the
risk of you dying is so much greater
than it is of a man that that more than
compensates for the fact that the person
you're going up against might not be
able to bash your head in with a rock
yes absolutely I mean I certainly agree
with all you're saying I have a new
paper on self-protection as a key driver
of girls and women's lives and part of
it is the reason I think across
societies women live longer than men and
they do and this is true with other
species as well but it's it's pretty
strong fact it fluctuates the degree but
is that women take better care of
themselves so whether that's going to
the doctor before you have to go to the
hospital whether it's suicide attempt as
a cry for help I don't think women are
incompetent I think if women really
wanted to die they could figure it out
just as well as men can I think it's a
fact that women don't want to die they
need some help though they need you know
they need a lot they need support so I
think there's many areas I mean I I love
the studies on pain which kind of is
relevant to what you're saying women
have a much lower threshold for
perceiving a painful stimulus whether
you give them electric shock or put
their hand in freezing water or burning
or whatever it is there's lots of
horrible experiments like this and
actually they're not unethical you know
but women can't stand as much as men and
that's so protective right because then
you're less likely to get injured your
body's telling you get away from this
stimulus it's not good for you women are
more likely to wake up in the middle of
the night good idea because in the
middle of the night there could be some
kind of Predator around and you want to
make sure that you see it first women
are much better in terms of mounting an
immune response so women die less from
most things and if you want to bring up
covet or whatever it is around the world
these are really strong effects in terms
of social altercations women are much
less likely verbally and physically to
be
dangerous in how they resolve something
so they'd rather avoid the whole thing
they might say oh my gosh stay away from
her she horrible outside of your shot
but they're going to be much careful
women are much more neurotic they worry
more they're they feel more vulnerable
than men that's good that means we're
more protective I'm the first to admit
to all of these things I'm not in any
way putting down women I'm trying to say
this is why we stay a lot alive longer
this is
to me the heart of what a woman is it's
staying alive and keeping your children
alive and keeping your family members
and your support system alive and that's
to me really important to to realize
one of the things that's kind of
interesting is this denial of sex
differences right the fact that men and
women are a blank slate that
fundamentally all of our differences
come from socialization or whatever some
superstructure that's doing that what
I've come to believe having a lot of
conversations like this throughout 2022
is that this does a real disservice to
women mostly it doesn't do that much of
a disservice to men I mean it calls men
some mean things and it it can kind of
lambast them as being these sort of
tyrants but what it really does is it
doesn't
it doesn't appropriately respect the
subtle
razor that feminine
wisdom and brutality and manipulation
can wield in an effective manner it's
like there are some things that are
really really good that that women can
do with that regard there you know why
would it be the case that a lower
threshold for pain
that you can feel it at would be
something that
you should be ashamed of it's keeping
you alive it's keeping your children
alive it's avoiding any risks occurring
from I'm gonna guess as well that women
have probably got higher discussed uh
they're more sensitive to discuss
they're probably more sensitive to
pathogens
all of the above uh and seeing that is I
don't know something that should be that
you should be embarrassed about or that
should be shamed or that true Freedom or
true Independence means acting like your
father rather than acting like your
mother
um that doesn't seem right to me and it
it is at odds with the way that women
are as well which is What's worst
so I can't agree more strongly I mean
being sensitive which women are
oftentimes accused of or they're
dismissed when they're worried about
things is what keeps women alive it
being attentive to who died where and
how did they die and what's wrong with
me and anyone I know is absolutely
critical but the one point I would
disagree with you on is I think sex
differences are really critical to men
and women so if I just take the first
letter of the alphabet right aggression
men are dying from aggression all over
the world whether it's Warfare or
intra-community aggression and and we
need to do something about that
autoimmune diseases that's a woman's
disease right men have cardiovascular
diseases and women have different
manifestations that are being ignored if
we take anxiety that's a huge problem
for women and growing it's terrible so
ADHD this is a big problem for boys I'm
just talking about A's I I think
diseases and whether they're physical or
you want to call them mental because I
don't know that mental is not physical
at some level it doesn't make sense to
me I think if we're going to understand
human nature and try to improve our
society we have to look at sex
differences this is critical and it's
absolutely true we don't want to make
fun of one sex and women do get made fun
of more and it's totally unfair and
stupid because that's how we're keeping
ourselves alive but on top of that men
have a lot of serious problems that I
thought Richard Reeves book was terrific
it was fantastic yeah and the only way
only place I would disagree with it is I
think there's
a lot of ways that men can work together
as a group and improve our world and we
need them and without men being on board
we're not going to survive what I've got
in my head at the moment is a
conversation I keep on having this year
as well about
um why it is that women females on
average are more obsessed with True
Crime and serial killer documentaries
and podcasts and such like and uh my
opinion my stance is that the equivalent
of that is guys that learn about the
mafia from New York in the 70s and the
80s or you know gangsters from London
and the West End and stuff like that and
it's got me thinking today
what is it that women are learning about
it's life and death it's risks to their
own health it's potential pathogens what
is it that men are learning about it's
Tribal Warfare it's in group and out
group it's conflict
exactly I totally agree this is the
woman who died in that last month in New
Hampshire on the mountain I mean we were
riveted this is It's terrifying like how
could this happen so close to us with
someone who is so similar to us we need
to figure this out and that's it the
true crime in all of it it's really
important to survival and it's riveting
what about
women interfering in the relationships
and the um mating opportunities that
other women have
well I mean men do that too of course
but women it's it's a huge deal I mean
if you can get a higher status husband
who is going to invest in you and your
children in our society right in our
society that's a huge Boon and it allows
you to be free to work or not work if
you have a child who has a problem you
can stay home with them it's just
fantastic
um from so many different perspectives
and of course we know SES socioeconomic
status determines how long you and your
children live so if you have a man who's
you know pulling in the money and he can
give you a big house and better food and
more security and everything that any
primate would want and the male is going
to provide it hey it would be crazy not
to get that man so of course there's a
lot of jocking there's a lot of
competition
safely right in in often solitary
fashion if you can do it without anybody
else paying attention what would that be
would that be gossiping to the Friends
of the potential male partner perhaps
like trying to feed
aspiring information up exactly uh
reputation to integration right and any
social ostracism of a woman who might be
candidate for this man and Men pay
attention to it it's not just other
women men will pay attention too so
there is a huge advantage to having
higher socioeconomic status there there
is no question and a man really helps
with that so um I'm a little surprised I
think that girls aren't hurt by
um just having single mothers because I
think just in terms of money and status
and education and so forth having a
second person even if it were you know
married to another woman right just
having a second person investing in you
go gotta make a big difference to anyone
you know now for boys right now the
culture seems to be maybe worse I'm not
sure because boys have never done well
in school and they've never liked it and
it's so you know it's unpleasant that
there's girls there now too competing
with these boys and when there never
used to be so it really is tough on
these boys I think you're right what
we're not really seeing a massive amount
of
what you're seeing is a finally a
yardstick that boys can be compared to
when it talks about going through school
now that being said uh the number of
people that dropped out of college
during covid seven times more males than
females dropped out of college
um you know you're seeing rates of
University attendance drop for men so
it's not just the case that you have
women sort of blasting through and and
overachieving you also do have this what
seems to be underachievement of men
whether they're retreating into porn and
video games whether they're being
distracted by social media whether
they're being hijacked up and
liturgically whether it is a zero-sum
game there are a limited number of
spaces at colleges and and time that
teachers can spend focusing on boys it
seems like female teachers have a
predisposition for helping girls out
that girls get better outcomes when they
are taught by females and most teachers
are female the same boy and girl will go
into the head teacher's office for the
same transgression the boy is treated
much more harshly because girls or
females don't seem to be able to like
observe the misbehaving Rough and Tumble
play that boys can do in the same manner
that they could you know all of that
theory of Mind stuff so I I do get it
and I know it's it's just such a
fascinating time I really do think that
the next
two to five years will be the two main
topics that will be discussed will be
the mating crisis so why it is the
educated women are struggling to find
men that they're attracted to and this
listlessness and lack of place for men I
think that for me
um that that consists of two really like
good candidates for what's going to be
top of a top of headlines
it it makes lots of sense I would just
add disease you know understanding
diseases because there's so many sex
differences whether in the same disease
or which diseases are most prevalent
excuse me what like
oh well I mean chronic fatigue syndrome
Long Haul covid whatever you you know
these are different diseases
fibromyalgia
um all the autoimmune diseases I mean
these are
preponderantly females you know it's
just a huge huge difference and you know
the types of what we want to talk about
suicide as a disease if you want to talk
about
um you know these deaths of Despair
they're they're overwhelmingly male so
if we're trying to understand the types
of problems that that men and women have
and there's whole organizations devoted
to understanding Women's Health in the
United States there's there's groups and
there should be for a man's health the
the problem is
um it's always been Men's Health so men
are more likely to survive a heart
attack just because most of the research
on heart attacks has included men so
it's really important that women are
included and and there's more advanced
but there's I would say there's almost
no disease and and I'm going out on a
limb here but almost no disease where
there aren't sex differences because
both the mechanics as well as the
prevalence
um are totally different it just makes
me Furious in terms of inoculations
women have a much stronger immune
response to inoculation so women don't
like to get the inoculations as much as
men do and men don't want to take care
of themselves and so now we're talking
about it so we're talking about death
you know we're talking about uh response
oftentimes women will have twice as many
antibodies produced in response to a
particular vaccine but they make the
vaccines for men because they don't want
to bother and look at the sex
differences so they make sure it's as
much as possible to help a man who needs
more help
that's a very interesting way to think
about the compensating for it because
I've heard this a good bit that medicine
for a very long time studied the bodies
of men because it was men that were
easier to study cadaver so on and so
forth but
it's also interesting to think that
because the male immune system appears
to be weaker in some regards than the
female one optimizing treatments for men
makes the most sense because if it works
for a man it'll definitely work for a
woman now I'm sure that there are tons
of outliers here with regards to the way
that our physiologies differ but
certainly when it comes to immunizing if
that's the case and you get basically
double the efficacy or somewhere close
for women
make it work just make it work for the
guys the girls will be okay however
there is still this uh that's a very
unpopular view right to sort of just
have known as the byproduct of whatever
it is that is being designed for men I I
just wanna break in and interrupt hey as
a female because the side effects from
these vaccines are much much worse
across the board for women and and and
for girls so there's more pain and there
are many many more side effects in terms
of being in bed and being exhausted and
getting headaches and so it's not
innocuous it's not just oh well who
cares we'll throw away half a dose of
vaccine it's really tough for for women
to have to deal with that and men don't
even notice and then they say oh you're
too sensitive and there's no uh
understanding that it's the immune
system that is giving this extra strong
response too so just antigens so I know
that you've written yourself you talked
about Richard Reeves today you've
written about the the feminization the
so-called feminization of men what have
you what have you come to believe about
the modern world and its feminization of
men or lack thereof yeah I mean I
haven't written about that really I mean
most of my work has been looking at at
boys and and girls and seeing uh the
really strong differences and I don't
see boys as being feminized at all I I
see the Rough and Tumble play I see the
group Behavior I see the enemies I see
the competition
um yes it's true that if you're in
educational institution
um that's much more geared toward girls
conscientiousness and and sedentary
behavior and being polite and so forth
um but so I I really haven't written you
know about that too much I don't know
know that much about it but I do think
that Society because of men's efforts
have made things much easier for women
to go out in the workplace we have you
know washing machines and dishwashers
and all kinds of things so we have more
free time and typical tasks taken care
of by by women so men have done that and
and now you know they're they're out of
a job and and we're out there so I think
I think that's true but I I've always
admired very much all that men have
contributed they've created our society
our society is man-made because women
have been keeping everyone alive which
to me is more important nonetheless our
society our our contemporary Society in
the west is man-made and I think so I
think we have to give credit where
credit is due that that is the case
um if only we could take some of these
problems that you say are so amorphous
like environmental destruction or
whatever it is or and um make them
War yeah galvanized men in some sort of
a way I mean we're seeing this with
video games as a good example you know
you mentioned that social media appears
to be the video games for girls and if
you can
uh commercialized weaponize motivate
that group bonding status seeking goal
striving vasopressin dopamine system if
you can grab it and Wrangle it and and
attach it to something you can be a
commander of a Starship Fleet or a
soldier that's out at war or a
futuristic robot that's trying to build
a castle or whatever right there's a
million different things that you can do
um and it is
it is interesting to consider whether
we've managed to create a world where
all of the things that men would
typically be striving to do is so
readily available without them having to
leave their house that we've basically
sedated men out of their usefulness in
the real world
yes I agree with that I mean I really do
the only disagreement I would have with
Richard Reeves is he wants men to
replace women in the home and I don't
see that natural inclination there are
some men who would want to do that but I
don't see in terms of teaching and in
terms of just most health care
um you know nurses and and social
workers and so forth I don't see men
being that interested in it now it's
great if men can be encouraged to do
that but I think it's more these big big
problems and we need you know we need
agriculture to change and we need so
many things to change in our world and
men as groups they're still there in all
the emergency situations certainly you
think of an emergency and the men who
are going to be there so I I I think
we're not yet there but I think we're
getting there and and we need to be able
to think of how to as you said make it
really emotionally satisfying I would
add though I don't think social media is
like video games for for boys and Men I
think boys and men really love shooting
and and so forth I think girls feel if I
don't get on social media No One's Gonna
like me and I need to know that people
like me I need to know every day and
every hour maybe that people like me and
look at her she's doing so well and oh
my gosh I feel terrible about it but I
have to look I can't stop looking and I
don't think it's pleasurable and I I do
think that women and girls are having a
hard time now it's not just that boys
and men are having a hard time I think
society's failing all of us in terms of
lack of community and and lack of
support so I do think that we need to
change I would agree
how have you managed to sustain an
academic career talking about sex
differences in a time when this is some
of the most contested least popular work
and I looked at your Google Scholar
earlier on today and you're getting more
prevalent I don't know what you've been
eating or drinking over the last few
years but you're releasing more papers
per year than you ever seem to have done
before
how have you still got a job
um the truth is I've had a number of
different jobs but I'm not interested in
the politics I'm truly interested in
science and loads of people say that
loads of people aren't interested in the
politics and the politics get inserted
into the science that they're doing yeah
I mean nobody I I mean I'm hesitant to
say this but nobody has ever attacked my
attack my work honestly
um it's too boring it's kind of like I'm
this is my data and this is what I find
and I think very highly of the way boys
and men do things and I think very
highly of the way girls and women do
things I just think they're different so
I'm not putting down one sex or the
other and and I do think
um it's really really really important
for life itself to understand sex
differences and of course right now I
have to say I've kind of
um taken myself out of that world
because I'm teaching in a human
evolutionary biology department so I'm
teaching about non-human primates I'll
relate it to humans but nobody in class
has ever said to me how could you say
that female chimpanzee is different than
that male chimpanzee or the baboon or
whatever species I'm talking about which
is that's what I talk about nobody has
ever said that to me oh it's socialized
the fact is it is socialized you know uh
whatever species you are you're brought
up in as a mammal for many many years by
a mother who you know treats you one way
if you're a male another if you're
female and the community treats you
differently and so yeah socialized too
but nobody has any complaint so right
now I'm a little bit in a safe space
because I am in a biology Department
um maybe that's part of my answer I
understand you've got to get out of jail
free card Joyce you're an absolute
Legend I've been really looking forward
to speaking to you all your everyone
that I've spoken to is sunyo prices very
highly and I can see why uh what are you
working on next let's say that someone
loves what you've been talking about
today what can they expect from you over
the next few months
well I mean I have uh work on status and
trying to understand how women and men
uh cope with different status
um uh levels and to me it's fascinating
because as you as we began you said men
are more competitive more more
interested in gaining status for
themselves and so I just did a paper and
it's under review now but I said okay
how would most women you feel so I said
be an expert for me and this was this
online study I referred to How would how
would most women feel if another woman
got a great car or a great house or a
great
um I had all kinds of things or had lots
of relatives helping her out or you know
how how do women feel when this happens
a woman does really well for herself and
how would a man feel so we ask women
about women and we ask men about men and
we said for people that you know how
would you feel and the women felt worse
than the men and that to me says it all
because it basically says yeah men want
to get the status they're they're really
motivated to get status but if some
other guy gets it he gets it there's
just not the same oh how could she have
this and it was amazing to me how many
of our items the women felt worse that
another woman had something she didn't
do and women have a much more zerosome
mentality when it comes to this
uh well I mean I think it's again going
back to this egalitarian ethos
um I I don't know that it's zero sum but
it's
um no I wouldn't even say it's zero sum
because in some way you could say the
man said okay they got it all and I
didn't get any too bad for me but good
for them yeah okay with the woman it's
her gain is my loss or at least that's
how it's perceived well it's an
interesting question how it's perceived
this will be where my future is you know
in the immediate future what is going on
that a woman could actually say and this
is across three several countries a
woman could actually say I feel terrible
that that woman got a really expensive
car right that's a male thing right or I
feel terrible that that woman bought
this beautiful house because I don't I
don't have that and to feel as bad or
worse than men and overall for more we
had 22 items women felt worse there was
not a single item men felt worse on
women felt worse on about half of the
items and Men didn't feel worse than
women on any item um it was incredible
you know even having a high status job
you would think men who didn't have a
high status job would feel worse if this
guy they know has a high status no the
women feel worse if a woman another
woman they know has a high status job
and she doesn't and so it's like wow I
mean to me this was just eye-opening so
it's under review now and that's kind of
what you said I'm trying to understand
what are what are you thinking are the
men saying well I try and that's it good
for him or or I'm keeping trying and
maybe eventually I'll get there and are
the women saying oh it's hopeless then
or I don't know I don't understand it
but I was really really surprised it was
so consistent all right Joyce thank you
very much for today I appreciate you
okay you're welcome thanks for inviting
me what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]